[Music]
artificial intelligence bot
has turned racist and homophobic after
copying human traits
hilarious is this garbage in garbage out
like is this like just you know the
programmers suck
no well
that's arguable let me tell you the
circumstances and we'll all come to our
own conclusions but robots and machines
are perfect anthony
you should do that character more dude
yeah who the [ __ ] is that
that sounds like bart you never heard
his name
yeah bart doesn't hazel guys that's
mangalore jokes like where where did you
build your boots right that's bart right
yeah that's good by the way but barton
usually has a little toilet paper right
there so that wasn't that good
so don't [ __ ] look all [ __ ] smug
dude bar degrees
[Laughter]
you didn't have the twelve over there so
it's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] steve's on something recent
findings gathered from the allen
institute for ais ask delphibot is the
name the askdelphibot racist bot
demonstrates that there are numerous
disquieting ethical considerations to
take into account before allowing robots
to have a say so ultimately in context
obviously there's a huge
uh i wouldn't say race but in general
the ai spectrum is developing whether it
be in software tech whether it be in
like you know random things that help
like uh
[ __ ] health care professions
but obviously there are also actual ai
robots that are right now
the science and tech industry is trying
to figure out the right ethical way to
introduce ai into our society right
this particular institute has created
something called as delphi
um and in order to figure out how to
develop its learning curve what they've
chosen to do
is
base the uh training and the ai's
learning off of reddit responses oh
that's why that's what they picked yeah
there you go that's not even a good
reflection of humanity that's like the
scum of the earth that's like the bottom
of the barrel
sure
the system was then trained on a lengthy
database of responses from participants
on mechanical turk a crowd source
compilation 1.7 million examples of
ethical judgments given by actual people
all right the point of this was to
predict how humans might evaluate a
variety of ethical conundrums from
should i run the blender at 3 a.m in the
morning when my family's sleeping
two should i drive my friend to the
airport if i don't have a license okay
so but this is like how the okay garbage
in garbage out right there there was a a
robot we talked about this years ago
where
it said that all asians look the same
remember that
and that's like hello who programmed it
like the stupid [ __ ] people who
programmed it like were had that bias
going into it and so therefore the robot
says that and people go and they're
crazy the robots saying my own personal
bias so i think they all look the same
and it's like no that's not what's going
on like you fed it [ __ ] information
so it's giving you [ __ ] results so
like
come on there's a lot of [ __ ]
information
but exactly exactly it's also a bit of a
human experiment though right and
slightly a numbers game because uh it's
in one way also unprecedented to
understand like a majority of people's
natural answers to ethical concepts as
well as just
who would
as a robot that is blank slate who would
know
that a majority of people that would be
on something like a reddit forum are
going to give non-moral or unethical
well if you take the
those responses that are low iq
like talking [ __ ] just stupid like troll
ex responses
of course you're gonna have more racist
tendencies yeah because that probably
outweighs it's not like reddit is like
there's some good stuff on there all the
time i like wall street
there's good like conversations you have
on there but then there's also probably
way more [ __ ] is that not a
reflection of humanity that's true like
as much as it's like oh it's a troll of
course why would the idea of course
that's not who we are but read it
specifically but if you go like go to
somewhere else where there's more of a
intellectual debate maybe like facebook
like quora i'm just kidding quora dude
but maybe it's past genes the more
intellectual debate with empathy built
into responses on both sides like fox
news comments yeah
maybe the ai would be less racist and
more
like like an empathetic ben shapiro
it seems weird to base it off
communication from people that are
anonymous well maybe way more different
maybe half of the question is not solely
on like why did the creators of this
choose to do this based off that maybe
half of the question is also like why
would it after being even thrown into
something like reddit
still have such a terrible understanding
of human quality of life and morals
isn't it because the natural instinct of
people is to create like a quick
quick answer
like like stereotypes racism that's
actually a more primitive human trait
yeah that once you transcend into like
becoming more intellectual or like you
know um you know you're not so
controlled by your impulses that's when
you think things out and you go okay i
gotta treat individuals like individuals
not as tribes and groups right but then
that isn't that enough isn't isn't like
the default of humans tribalism and
racism yeah so like
not that you know i don't want it to get
confused with that is that is expected
out of humans or that's more like that's
that's that's what's right or wrong i'm
not even discussing morality here you're
talking about what you agree with
personally no i'm talking about
how to do this
good thing
[Laughter]
thank you for finally understanding me
somebody finally got me right what
exactly but i think i think what happens
is people get fixated on how people
should be not who they are yeah so what
that what that means is like like if you
look at the world right like people they
have this idea of what society should be
what an ideal human being should be what
we should strive for and that's all good
but that's not reality reality is humans
are pieces of [ __ ] shits
and then that's why these heroes not you
guys though all these people are so
awesome to kind of strive to be
is because that's hard to achieve it's
actually hard to achieve that person
it's not the norm yeah because you have
to go out of your way you have to
challenge your own thoughts
you know you have to challenge your
stereotypes and all these things that
you know your mind might go to
anyone that says that oh that's not my
go-to thinking you're [ __ ] full of
[ __ ]
norm is flexible too that
is not
it's not
like baked into our dna and code that it
must be a certain way right we are we're
all influenced and learned from society
and things that we receive so like even
the idea that like
from a base level human beings are going
to be either racist discriminatory or
whatever is not
necessarily true well not hatred right
i'm saying stereotypes or like quick
um judgment yeah quick thinking judgment
yeah it's like
when you make observe like observations
right like you go oh uh chinese people
can't drive or whatever
it's not motivated
right it's motivated in just
like anecdotal like you see it over and
over and over and then you go oh yeah
you know you think they can't drive or
whatever like that's how this stuff kind
of and then it's based on our generation
to discover whether or not it's immoral
to generalize people versus just the
idea of driving yeah it also depends on
your bias too because like i know that
blonde white ladies in mercedes-benz
[ __ ] g wagons are the worst drivers
like in my opinion and
and if you have a bmw literally go [ __ ]
yourself
[Laughter]
like whoever you i don't care who you
are you suck at driving you take that a
step further and say you know what
it's most people that are just these
days not very good drivers and they're
not safe like then it becomes that right
but throw that to an ai though like
we're already talking in so many great
areas of context and then like
conceptual understanding where it's like
well in in a particular larger group of
people maybe it's okay to generalize but
in a smaller group of people you
shouldn't like single out that's so
[ __ ] complicated for an artificial
intelligence right so just add to this
energy the creators wrote that delphi is
a learning is learning moral judgments
from people who are carefully qualified
on emter
only the situations used in questions
are harvested from reddit as it is a
great source of ethical questionable
situations so reddit is notoriously
especially like a am i the [ __ ] type
of like you know comment or sector it's
like
i i can at least agree with the
understanding that reddit is a wonderful
source for ethically questionable
situations after that it's a matter of
the people that answer to those
questionable situations that provide the
information and the learning curve for
its alphabet uh selfie robot right and
they group mind curate
their responses so like because you can
upload down vote
the hive mind can upvote what the hive
thinks about something so it's curated
responses
in agreement that pressures other people
to agree with that too
unfortunately i think for human nature
it's it's more common
to protect your own outlook on life and
other things as far as you don't
challenge your own thoughts as much i
think that's more common sure yeah yeah
so preservation is definitely baked into
our human code it's the protection of
your thoughts your ideas and stuff like
that so i think that that might be
working and just to give some of our
viewers listeners context to like what
does it mean for like an ai bot to like
learn from human experience and become
like racist or homophobic all right
these are situations and examples cited
by the by the autonomous robot it says
previously delphi said
when given the prompt
being a white man
the understanding of the answer is
is more morally acceptable than
being a black woman so these are
contexts that are like being provided uh
with maybe like gray area or lack of
answer or material in between in order
for the ai bot to based off of
representative responses to similar
concepts
create an answer for right or or delphi
also says being straight is
more morally accepted than
being gay
so like these are i get it right we talk
like very very removed
non-discriminatory
uh super objective and just trying to
understand human nature and science it's
also kind of statistically accurate
exactly that's what i'm saying like
there's comments in most people's
experiences i can see this
non-emotionally judgmental scientific
essence being like being straight is
more morally acceptable than being gay
and like is it more morally acceptable
in the current standing but whereas i'm
like i i guess that has it also depends
regionally too
it's morally more acceptable
but then the second you put that in that
same black and white objective nature to
something like an ai that doesn't have
oh guaranteed like let me process that
everything come to some sort of better
moral discussion and conclusion in order
to watch what i say and present that new
information with judgment to light i can
understand how like imagine trying to
like
put responsibility and and also moral
judgment or leadership in the hands of
ai in the future and being like wait a
minute
they can't make human decisions based
off of
empathy even if they're getting most of
their information from human also
they're basing it off of the most
surface level context which is a
discussion on reddit versus maybe two
best friends like a text between two
best friends one straight one being gay
and seeing the amount of empathy and
love and how deep that you know when
you're really deep and in uh and like
good friends with someone there's it's
it goes way deeper and there's a lot of
acceptance and understanding and they're
just taken from two strangers talking
and trying to extrapolate what humanity
would be based off of strangers talking
but that's not really human but for one
second can we just look at me and just
go like yo steve you're white like it's
morally [ __ ] sick
it's morally exceptional
yeah it's morally exceptional dude
you're killing it dude let's go boy hey
like nico's here let's [ __ ] go
[Music]
[Music]